PRESIDENT'S SPEECH AS SOON AS
THAT HAPPENS.
BUT FIRST, SET THE STAGE WITH
OUR "HANNITY" WATCH ON THE
VERY WALL NEGOTIATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN ONGOING.
NOW FOR DAYS DEMOCRATS, THEY
HAVE BEEN UP TO THE OLD
TRICKS.
ONCE AGAIN PLAYING POLITICS
TRYING TO TORPEDO BORDER
SECURITY TALKS WITH WHAT IS AN
OUTRAGEOUS DEMAND AIMED --
THINK ABOUT THIS -- AT
CURTAILING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF I.C.E.
WE KNOW THEY WANT TO ABOLISH
IT IN THE END.
OVER THE WEEKEND WE LEARNED
DEMOCRATIC NEGOTIATORS -- LOOK
AT THIS -- THEY WERE PUSHING
FOR ARBITRARY CAP ON THE
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
THAT I.C.E. WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO DETAIN AT ONE TIME.
AND THE DEMOCRATS, THEY WANTED
TO SET THE CAP AT ONLY 16,500
INDIVIDUALS.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF CAPACITY
EXCEEDS THAT NUMBER FOR ANY
REASON, UNVETTED, UNVERIFIED,
UNDOCUMENTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WOULD ESSENTIALLY
POUR FREE IN TO UNITED STATES
AND BORDER ENFORCEMENT WOULD
BE POWERLESS TO STOP THEM.
EVEN CRIMINALS.
THOSE WITH VIOLENT TRACK
RECORDS, GANG TIES, CARTEL
TIES WOULD ALL BE FREE TO
ENTER THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
AND NOT FACE ANY IMMIGRATION
DETENTION.
KEEP IN MIND, LOOK AT THE LAST
TWO YEARS ALONE.
266,000 ARRESTS OF CRIMINAL
ALIENS HAVE BEEN CARRIED OUT.
INCLUDING 100,000 ASSAULT
CHARGES.
13,000 SEX CRIMES CHARGES.
4,000 MURDER, HOMICIDE
CHARGES.
AND AS WE SPEAK, NEARLY
180,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
LIVE RIGHT HERE IN THE
U.S. INCLUDING SOME OF THE
VIOLENT FELONS THAT ARE
ALREADY FACING REMOVAL ORDERS.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO CAP I.C.E.
DETENTION AT 16,500.
WELL, THAT IS INSANE BECAUSE
16,5001 AND WHAT IF IT TURNED
OUT TO BE A MURDER, RAPIST OR
PART OF A DRUG CARTEL?
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
CALLING FOR MORE FUNDING, MORE
RESOURCES, MORE SECURITY, TO
TACKLE THE SCOURGE OF DRUGS,
GANG VIOLENCE, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, SEX TRAFFICKING
OF THE YOUNG GIRLS AND MORE
DEMOCRATS SEEM CONTENT WHICH
TRYING TO MAKE THE BORDER
SECURITY WHAT?
MORE DIFFICULT?
NOW, LOOK, THE PRESIDENT IS
FOUGHTING THIS AS IT IS.
A LIFE AND -- FIGHTING THIS AS
IT IS.
A LIFE-AND-DEATH ISSUE.
THIS IS ABOUT YOUR FAMILY'S
SAFETY AND SECURITY FIRST.
DEMOCRATS ONCE AGAIN PLAYING
JUST PURE POLITICS.
IT'S PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS.
THEY SEEM TO HATE DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT IS MORE IMPORTANT TO THEM
BASED ON THEIR ACTIONS THAN
YOUR SECURITY, YOUR FAMILY
SECURITY, MORE IMPORTANT THAN
DACA, DREAMERS, EVEN
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES THAT THEY
CLAIM TO CARE SO MUCH ABOUT.
THESE ARE THE THINGS THEY SAY
THEY WANTED.
JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS AGO.
IN OBAMA'S SECOND TERM.
THEY WERE ADVOCATING THE SAME
POLICIES DONALD TRUMP IS NOW
PUSHING HARD FOR.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL PUT IT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE
RADICALS, AS I'VE BEEN SAYING
THE RADICAL EXTREMIST NEW
SOCIALIST PARTY IS RUNNING THE
SHOW.
TAKE LOOK.
>> Senator McConnell: THIS
IS A POISON PILL THAT NO
ADMINISTRATION, NOT THIS ONE,
NOT THE PREVIOUS ONE WOULD OR
SHOULD EVER ACCEPT.
IMAGINE THE ABSURDITY OF THIS.
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
SET A LIMIT ON HOW MANY
CRIMINAL ALIENS GOVERNMENT CAN
DETAIN.
THIS IS WHERE SOME DEMOCRATS
ARE.
A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD
FOR CRIMINALS BECAUSE THE
RADICAL LEFT DOESN'T LIKE
U.S. IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Sean: NOW FOR MONTHS WE
TOLD YOU THE RADICAL EXTREME
LEFT HAS CONSUMED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW WE'RE WATCHING WHAT?
OPEN BORDERS.
THAT AGENDA PLAY OUT IN REAL
TIME.
THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE I.C.E.
BUT AMERICANS NOW ARE WAKING
UP AND WAKING UP VERY, VERY
QUICKLY AND SEEING HOW EXTREME
THE NEW DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY IS.
NOW THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
RATING, LOOK AT THIS.
HIS HIGHEST POINT IN TWO
YEARS.
LOOK AFTER THE "STATE OF THE
UNION."
CBS EVENING NEWS POLL.
72% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
APPROVED OF THE PRESIDENT'S
"STATE OF THE UNION" REMARKS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
SO, BY THE WAY IF YOU ARE
ARAME, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENATE -- IF YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENATE -- WE WILL TALK TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM TONIGHT -- IT'S
TIME TO TAKE A STAND AND DO
YOUR JOB AND FULFILL YOUR
PROMISES AND STOP BEING SO
AFRAID OF EVER BEING
COURAGEOUS.
KEEP YOUR PROMISES TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, WE WILL SEE, BECAUSE
IF THEY DID THAT WE'D BE SAFER
AS MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
COMPROMISE BECOME AVAILABLE.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
IF YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN SENATOR
OR HOUSE MEMBER AND YOU ARE
TOO WEAK TO STAKE A STAND IT'S
PROBABLY TIME FOR YOU TO
RETIRE.
GO HOME.
LET SOMEBODY WHO IS WILLING TO
FIGHT TAKE YOUR PLACE.
IF DEMOCRATS, IF THEY CONTINUE
TO STONEWALL, PLAY POLITICS
WITH THE NATIONAL SECURITY,
DRUGS COMING IN THE COUNTRY IN
THIS BRAND NEW DEAL THAT WE'LL
FIND OUT MORE ABOUT, THE
PRESIDENT WILL HAVE NO CHOICE,
HE WILL VETO THIS.
AND DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
WHY?
BECAUSE AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF,
THE PRESIDENT HAS A LOT OF
PERFECTLY LEGAL OPTIONS FOR
BUILDING THE WALL.
INCLUDING LOOK AT THIS, 10.
USC.284.
IT GIVES THEM THE AUTHORITY TO
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION OF
ROADS, FENCES, INSTALLATION OF
LIGHTING TO DROP DRUG
SMUGGLING CORRIDORS ACROSS THE
INTERNATIONAL BOUNDARIES OF
THE UNITED STATES.
BY THE WAY, THE FENCE CAN BE
DEFINED A MILLION WAYS.
OF COURSE, THE PRIMARY
SMUGGLING CORRIDORS IN THE
U.S. ARE RIGHT THERE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT IS WHERE 90% OF THE
HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY COMES
FROM.
THOSE BORDERS.
THAT MEANS THAT HELPS PUT AN
END TO THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC IN
THE COUNTRY.
SO TONIGHT, CONGRESS HAS TWO
OPTIONS.
THEY DO THE JOBS.
THEY AGREE ON A COMPROMISE
THAT DOESN'T WEAKEN BORDER
SECURITY OR DO NOTHING.
S AND THEY CAN GET LEFT
BEHIND.
BECAUSE THE WALL, PREDICT, IS
GOING TO BE FUNDED AND GOING
TO BE BUILT.
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT IS
UNRELENTING, TENACIOUS AND
DOING EVERYTHING AND WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN HIS POWER TO
KEEP HIS PROMISE, GET THIS
DONE, EVEN DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, WHICH MAY
EVEN HAPPEN THIS WEEK.
IF THAT IS WHAT IT TAKES,
FINE.
THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES.
HE TACK AN OATH TO PROTECT
THIS COUNTRY.
DO YOU NOT WANT TO BE
PROTECTED AND MORE SECURE?
DO WE WANT TO STOP THE
CARTELS, THE GANGS, MS-13,
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, DRUG
TRAFFICKERS, THOSE THAT WE
HAVEN'T VETTED THAT MAY BRING
HARM TO OUR FELLOW AMERICANS?
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
THIS AGREEMENT ENTAILS.
I'M VERY DUBIOUS.
ALSO, OF COURSE, WHEN THE FAR
LEFT RADICALS INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHEN THEY ARE
CALLING THE SHOTS LIKE
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR,
NEGOTIATIONS ARE PROBABLY
LIKELY TO BREAK DOWN.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE PUBLICLY
ACCUSED BORDER OFFICIALS
TORTURING REFEREE -- REFUGEES
OR THE BORDER PATROL HAD TO
USE TEAR GAS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST THE ROCKS
AND BOTTLES THROWN AT THEM?
THEY WERE ACCUSED OF GASSING
CHILDREN, REMEMBER?
TONIGHT IN THE "HANNITY" WATCH
ON THE EXTREME SOCIALIST PARTY
WE ARE SEEING A SAD EXTREME
CHAPTER UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR
EYES SURROUNDING CONGRESSWOMAN
OMAR.
FOR A GROUP THAT CONSTANTLY
TRIES TO CLAIM THE MORAL HIGH
GROUND ON EVERYTHING NOW THE
DEMOCRATIC MODERN EXTREME
RADICAL PARTY HAS AN
ANTISEMITISM THAT IS NOW
RUNNING AMOK INSIDE THE PARTY.
LOOK AT THIS OVER THE WEEKEND.
OMAR WAS LAMPOONED FOR A
SERIES OF ANTISEMITIC TWEETS
PUSHING A CONSPIRACY THEORY
THAT, "JEWISH MONEY WAS BEHIND
SUPPORT FOR AMERICA'S CLOSEST
ALLY IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
THE ONLY DEMOCRACY THERE.
SHE TWEETED.
"IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE
BENJAMINS."
AFTER PRESSURE FROM HER OWN
PARTY SHE IS "APOLOGIZING FOR
OFFENDING JEWISH AMERICANS."
BUT THE PROBLEM IS THIS IS
NOTHING NEW.
THEY KNOW WHO SHE IS AND WHAT
SHE HASLAM SAID IN THE PAST --
WHAT SHE HAS SAID IN THE PAST.
SHE IS OBSESSED WITH HATING
ISRAEL FOR A LONG TIME.
ONCE TWEETING NO APOLOGY,
ISRAEL HYPNOTIZED THE WORLD.
MAY ALLAH AWAKEN THE PEOPLE
AND HELP THEM SEE THE EVENING
DOINGS OF ISRAEL."
SADLY, OMAR IS NOT THE ONLY
DEMOCRAT WITH ANTISEMITIC
TIES.
IN 2006 HER COLLEAGUE
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB OFFERED
OP-ED FOR THE NATION OF ISLAM
PUBLICATION THAT IS CALLED
"THE FINAL CALL."
THIS IS JUSTIN LOUIS FARRAKHAN'S
PAPER WHO FREQUENTLY REFERS TO
JEWS AS SATAN TICK, TERMITES
AND -- SATANIC, TERMITES AND
WORSE.
HE ONCE SAID THAT HITLER WAS A
GREAT MAN AND JEWS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR 9/11.
THIS IS A SICK, DESPICABLE
ANTI-SEMITE.
THOSE WHO WRITE FOR THE PAPER
AND ASSOCIATE WITH HIM LIKE
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB, THIS IS
NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR A SITTING
CONGRESSWOMAN TO START WITH.
IT COMES ALSO AS THE OTHER
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS ARE FACING
MANY OF THEIR OWN SCANDALS
INVOLVING RACE.
LOOK AT THE COMMONWEALTH OF
VIRGINIA.
DISGRACED DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
RALPH NORTHAM.
HE IS DIGGING HIMSELF INTO AN
EVEN DEEPER HOLE AMID
CONTINUED CALLS TO STEP DOWN
FOLLOWING A RACIST YEARBOOK
PHOTO.
AND HIS ADMITTED USE OF
BLACKFACE IN THE '80s.
AFTER VOWING TO STAY IN OFFICE
TO PROMOTE RACIAL HEALING.
REALLY?
THEN THE GOVERNOR SAID THIS
OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
VIRGINIA'S SLAVE PATH.
LISTEN CLOSELY TO WHAT HE
SAYS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT VIRGINIA'S
HISTORY WE ARE NOW AT THE
400-YEAR ANNIVERSARY.
JUST 90 MILES FROM HERE IN
1619, THE FIRST INDENTURED
SERVANTS FROM AFRICA LANDED ON
OUR SHORES IN OLD POINT
COMFORT, WHAT WE CALL NOW FORT
MONROE.
>> ALSO KNOWN AS SLAVERY.
>> YES.
WHILE WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN VIRGINIA, SLAVERY
HAS ENDED, SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
DESEGREGATED, WE HAVE ENDED
THE GYM -- JIM CROW LAWS AND
ACCESS TO VOTING IT'S ABUDGET
DON'TLY CLARE WE HAVE --
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR WE HAVE WORK
TO DO.
>> Sean: NORTHAM'S REMARKS
IN THE SAGA HAVE SHOWN HIS
DEEP, DEEP DISCONNECT WITH THE
PEOPLE OF HIS STATE WHO
CERTAINLY DESERVE BETTER.
INDENTURED SERVANTS, REALLY?
THE TOP THREE LEADERS IN
VIRGINIA ARE ALL EMBROILED IN
SCANDAL INCLUDING THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR JUSTIN
FAIRFAX WHO IS REFUSING TO
STEP DOWN AFTER TWO SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS OF VIOLENT SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT.
AND IN ONE CASE HE IS ACCUSED
OF RAPE.
BY THE WAY, THE PERSON MAKING
THE ACCUSATION HAS MANY PEOPLE
THAT SHE TOLD AT THE TIME
BACKING UP HER STORY.
STAFF MEMBERS ARE REPORTEDLY
NOW QUITTING, REFUSING TO WORK
FOR THE EMBATTLED LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
BY THE WAY, WHERE ARE ALL THE
I BELIEVE, I BELIEVE, I
BELIEVE SENATORS?
WE'LL KEEP YOU UPDATED ON THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS.
OF COURSE, THE SCANDAL IN
VIRGINIA, IT ALL STARTED WITH
GOVERNOR NORTHAM'S RADICAL
POSITION WHERE HE ACTUALLY
ADVOCATED FOR OUT-AND-OUTRIGHT
INFANTICIDE.
FIRST HE SAID WE'LL DELIVER
THE BABY, MAKE THE BABY
COMFORTABLE AND THEN WE'LL LET
THE MOTHER DECIDE IF THERE IS
GOING TO BE ANY MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THE BABY.
REALLY?
THAT BILL LEGALIZING ABORTION
EVEN DURING THE BIRTHING
PROCESS.
AFTER NINE FULL MONTHS.
THIS IS INFANTICIDE.
PRETTY SICK STUFF.
TONIGHT THAT IS ONLY ONE IN A
LONG LIST OF THE RADICAL
POSITIONS OF THIS NEW EXTREME
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
INCLUDING MANY WHO ARE NOW
RUNNING FOR THE NOMINATION TO
BE PRESIDENT IN 2020.
FOR THEIR PARTY.
WHICH BRINGS US TONIGHT TO THE
"HANNITY" WATCH ON THE EXTREME
2020 DEMOCRATS.
WE'LL START WITH NEW JERSEY
SENATOR SPARTACUS, CORY
BOOKER.
COMPARING THE GREEN NEW DEAL
TO GOING TO THE MOON.
AND DEFEATING THE NAZIS.
BOOKER IS TALKING ABOUT
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S BIZARRE,
HORRIFIC NEW PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
LET'S SEE.
THAT WOULD PLAN THE END OF
CONSUMPTION OF FOSSIL FUELS IN
TEN YEARS.
BY THE WAY, THE PLANET IS
GOING TO DIE IN 12 YEARS.
WHAT IS THE POINT?
SERIOUSLY, DON'T WRITE OFF
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ
AND HER GRANDIOSE PLANS.
LOOK AT THE TEAMS THAT ARE NOW
COMING OUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS,
THIS GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
CALLS FOR NO MORE OIL, NO MORE
GAS, NO MORE FOSSIL FUELS OF
ANY KIND.
NOT EVEN ANY NUCLEAR ENERGY.
IT DOESN'T STOP THERE.
THIS BILL THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
AIRPLANES, GAS POWERED
AUTOMOBILES AND TRUCKS.
GAS-POWERED OVENS AND STOVES.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU LIKE STEAK.
NO MORE COWS TOO.
MUCH FLATULENCE.
THEY COMMIT CO2 EMISSIONS.
NO MORE COWS.
YOU BETTER LOAD UP ON THE
STEAK AND PUT IN A FREEZER.
HER PROPOSAL ALSO PLANS
LITERALLY TO REMODEL, REBUILD
AND RETROFIT EVERY BUILDING IN
AMERICA TO MEET THE INSANE NEW
ENERGY EFFICIENCY STANDARDS OF
HERS.
AND IT GETS WORSE.
ACCORDING TO HER OFFICE, EVERY
AMERICAN IS GUARANTEED A JOB
AND A SALARY.
BY THE WAY, WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE WILLING TO WORK OR
NOT.
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE TRYING TO
BACK DOWN ON THAT PART OF IT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GUARANTEED HEALTHCARE,
GUARANTEED JOBS, GUARANTEED
VACATIONS.
TRILLIONS AND TRILLIONS OF NEW
TAXES.
70% TAX RATE IS JUST THE
BEGINNING FOR HER.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
WILLING AND ABLE TO WORK,
WELL, BUT THAT IS JUST ONE
PART OF THE DEMOCRATS' INSANE
PUSH TO RADICALISM.
THE NEW PLATFORM.
ELIZABETH WARREN WANTS A NEW
TAX ON WEALTH.
THAT MEANS YOUR SAVINGS.
THAT IS MONEY THAT IS ALREADY
TAXED.
AFTER YOU PAY 50, 60 CENTS OF
EVERY DOLLAR, IF YOU MANAGE TO
SAVE ANYTHING SHE WANTS
ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE.
BY THE WAY, 40% WHEN YOU DIE.
THEY WANT ANOTHER BITE AT THE
APPLE.
ANOTHER 10% IF YOU LIVE IN NEW
YORK.
THEY WANT HALF AGAIN.
YOU PAY TO DIE IN AMERICA.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS WANTS TO
END ALL PRIVATE INSURANCE.
187 MILLION AMERICANS WIPED
OUT OF THEIR PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
BY THE WAY, TO PUT IN PLACE A
GOVERNMENT-RUN HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM CALLED "MEDICAL --
MEDICARE FOR ALL."
AND KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND SAYS
THE SAME.
NO MORE PRIVATE INSURANCE.
LISTEN.
THEY ARE MORE SOCIALIST THAN
THE CRAZY COUSIN BERNIE FROM
VERMONT.
SENATOR GILLIBRAND ALSO WANTS
TO COMPLETELY ABOLISH I.C.E.
AS DO OTHERS.
THIS IS THE PARTY OF HIGHER
TAXES, OPEN BORDERS,
ELIMINATING I.C.E., LATE-TERM
ABORTION AND GOVERNMENT
CONTROL OF ALL INDUSTRY AND
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE.
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE AWAY
ALL OF YOUR INSECURITIES AND
PROMISE YOU HEALTHCARE AND
HOUSING AND DAYCARE AND
COLLEGE AND A JOB AND A
VACATION.
OKAY.
THEN THEY ARE GOING TO
NATIONALIZE THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY.
HOW DID THAT OBAMACARE THING
WORK OUT?
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR, KEEP YOUR
PLAN AND SAVE LESS.
IN OTHER WORDS THEY WANT TO
TAKE CAPITALISM, THE VERY
SYSTEM THAT IS THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD, THAT IS LIFTED MORE
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY THAN ANY
OTHER SYSTEM IN HISTORY AND
FLUSH IT ALL DOWN THE TOILET
WITH NO HOPE OF EVER GETTING
IT BACK.
DESTROYING THE SINGLE BEST
WEALTH-PRODUCING STRUCTURE IN
THE HISTORY OF MAN.
EVEN POOR PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
COMPARE THEM AND THEIR LIVES
IN MOST CASES, IF YOU'RE NOT
HOMELESS, DO THEY HAVE RUNNING
WATER?
DO THEY HAVE TOILETS?
DO THEY HAVE KITCHENS?
DO THEY HAVE REFRIGERATORS?
FREEZERS?
ARE THEY ABLE TO COOK?
I HAVE BEEN TO SOME OF THE
POOREST HOUSING PROJECTS IN
AMERICA.
I HAVE BEEN INSIDE.
SO ASK YOURSELF.
ARE THOSE VALUES THAT WILL
MAKE AMERICA GREAT?
IMPROVE YOUR LIFE AT ALL?
DO YOU THINK ANYBODY WITH
MONEY IS GOING TO STAY HERE?
THEY ARE GOING TO LEAVE LIKE
THEY ARE LEAVING NEW YORK, NEW
JERSEY, ILLINOIS, AND
CALIFORNIA IN DROVES.
TENS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS A